[Applause]
[Music]
hello and welcome to the fifa 23 reveal
trailer i'm derek ray and alongside me
is stuart robson
thanks derek well you can really feel
the sense of anticipation as the players
warm up for their big moment on the
world stage
[Music]
and away we go
[Music]
it comes to sam kerr leading the chelsea
attack
sends us in holland
a pure strike
let's go backside where alex scott can
tell us more
well you're seeing hypermotion 2 in
action more animations than ever before
and more realism every time you step
onto the pitch
well he's going to wear out the right
stick playing like that
they say it's a game of two halves and
you can really feel the intensity
building here
oh he's mastered that one over the
summer
safe hands there it's incredible
calmness under pressure
oh a crunching challenge
[Music]
well that's duke
absolutely brilliant technique and it
feels like there's more goals coming in
this one
oh silky from vinicius
heart dribbling from son
weaving into space
[Music]
what were you thinking only one world
cup
that's got everyone in a celebratory
mood
we're into the final moments now what
else do they have up their sleeves and
it comes to care
and right in stoppage time
hold on what's killian up to here
[Applause]
[Music]
from the first frame to the embers
it's football everywhere
welcome to the world game
welcome to fifa 23.
[Music]